la france et la compagnie aérienne
nationale air france
vont elles se dissocier de la majorité
des gouvernements et des compagnies
aériennes occidentaux en guise de
représailles à l'encontre de l'union
soviétique après le drame du boeing
scorèrent 70% des vols des compagnies
aériennes occidentales à destination de
moscou sont en effet supprimer les
pilotes français doivent en principe à
partir de demain s'associer au
boycottage décidé par la fédération
internationale des pilotes
l'enquète de patrice pollet la france
rejoindra à partir de 0 heure cette nuit
11 des 26 pays de l'otan dans leur
mouvement de boycott de 60 jours décidée
par l'union internationale des pilotes
de ligne air france les vols seront
assurés comme celui de demain à 19h par
les pilotes qui ne suivront pas le
mouvement
une grande partie des équipages semble
cependant favorable au boycott pour eux
la consigne est la même le par prendre
la direction de moscou
nous avons pris la décision de suivre
cette consigne pour essayer d'obtenir
des améliorations des procédures
d'interception et de l'assistance que
limitèrent peuvent porter aux avions
civils en difficulté est-ce que vous
pensez que ce boycottage va être
largement suivie par les équipages
nous représentons 80% des équipages
qu'air france nous estimons que
la plupart des pilotes d'air france
suivront ce boycottage
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la décision
d'une compagnie par exemple que la
british airways qui non seulement est
favorable au boycott non plus interdit
aux avions soviétiques d'arrivée de
décoller cela le problème du boycott
tâche c'est un problème qui est lié aux
pilotes alors que l'arrivée ou latéraux
ou le lait non arrivées des vols de
l'air aux flottes et une décision du
gouvernement
ce matin à athènes à la réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères de la
communauté européenne l'allemagne de
l'ouest et la grande bretagne se sont
joints au japon et au canada pour
interdire l'atterrissage et le survol de
leur territoire par l'aviation
soviétique pendant une durée de 15 jours
et ceci à partir du 15 septembre la
france de ce côté ne suivra pas ce
mouvement
elle est en effet lié par un accord
bilatéral sur le trafic aérien avec
l'union soviétique en commentant ce
boycottage des vols sur moscou charles
fiterman ministre des transports a
déclaré aujourd'hui que ces sanctions ne
constituaient pas des mesures efficaces
pour l'objectif recherché
les vols en direction de moscou devrait
aussi se poursuivre grâce aux avions
supplémentaires que l'air aux flottes
mettra en service pour pallier les
déficiences du trafic international
à condition bien sûr qu'ils ne se dirige
vers un pays qui refuse de les recevoir
et le vol air france de demain matin est
maintenue c'est ce que vient d'annoncer
la direction d'air france